sopia tell us about the state of ftth
deployment in Luxembourg I know you're
one of the most advanced countries in
Europe yes we have already begun
relatively early to deploy fiber even in
a hybrid mode with fiber and copper
combined and this fiber was not used in
the beginning but it was there so when
we started really with our strategy for
fiber to the home we could really use
that and have already is a good starting
point and in 2010 we adopted our
strategy for ultra-high broadband and
now we are about fifty percent of the
households which are covered by five or
20 that's fantastic and I mean you've
obviously got the infrastructure already
but you talk about the strategy what is
the strategy going forward I know you
got everything planned out yes we the
strategy is to achieve fifty percent
coverage for a speed of one gigabit per
second by 2015 and to go to a hundred
percent by 2020 so the fiber will go on
to be deployed and we hope that we will
go towards that target that's fantastic
that's amazing and obviously Luxembourg
is known very much as a financial
business hot but I think one of the key
ingredients of what you've achieved is
looking after your residence when they
get home that the experience at home is
just as good as the experience at work
that is right i think for businesses
it's of course very important we also do
have done a lot of efforts to deploy the
fiber towards the activities of a the
businesses are but it's important now
that the whole society can have the
connectivity it need
and it's a for all the people also the
young people they want to have a good
connectivity so we think that it is
essential that we spread it to the whole
country that's fantastic thank you very
much for joining us thank you Brian so
look Samberg leading the way for Europe
in business and also at home